So now I'd like to introduce
today's speaker, Michael McGehee.
Michael McGehee is a professor
of materials science and
engineering at Stanford University, and
the co-director of our Energy Innovation
and Emerging Technologies certificate.
Which is offered through the Stanford
Center for Professional Development.
His primary research interests
are developing new materials for
smart windows and solar cells.
He's taught courses on nanotechnology,
organic semiconductors, solar cells, and
polymer science.
He received his undergraduate degree
in physics from Princeton University.
And his PhD was in Materials Science
from the University of
California at Santa Barbara.
There he did research on polymer lasers
in the lab of Nobel laureate Alan Heeger.
Michael has strong industry
connections acting
as a technical advisor to Next Energy,
PLANT PV and Sinovia.
And from his teaching and mentorship,
he has an impressive crowd
of alumni in his lab.
Many are now working in Silicon Valley
startups, nine of which have
their own companies, and four receiving
the Forbes' 30 under 30 award.
I'd now like to turn
the floor over to Michael.
>> Hello everyone.
Thank you for
participating in this webinar.
I'm going to bring you up to speed
on some exciting developments with
Perovskite semiconductors and their use
in solar cells, but to get started,
let me just say a couple things
about the solar industry in general.
In this graph here,
if you look at the orange curve,
you can see that back during the oil
crisis in the 70's solar panels cost
about $100 per watt of power that
they could generate in peak sunlight.
And then that dropped rapidly and
then stagnated
during the 90's when there wasn't
a whole lot of interest in solar energy.
And then in the last five or six years,
the price has dived down again and
now it's at about 50 or 60 cents per watt.
And with that price reduction,
if you look at the blue curve
you can see the installations
are rapidly rising with time.
And now about 65,000 megawatts
are being installed per year.
And that's about the equivalent
of 65 coal fired power plants.
So this is very, very exciting.
And even more broadly,
I would say that in the last year or
two we've reached a tipping point
on addressing climate change.
And a lot of people are getting
onboard ranging from politicians
to the utility companies and
I think there's a commitment now and
that renewable energy is
likely to do very well.
So solar still needs to get
a little bit better if the overall
cost of an installed system was
a bout one dollar per watt.
Then solar electricity would be about
the same cost as electricity from
a gas fired power plant, and here I've
only shown you the price for the panel.
Now installing the panel
is even more expensive.
And at a utility scale that
can be maybe $1.50 per watt.
And if you did it on a house,
it might be something like $3.5 per watt.
Now today, I'm going to be focusing
more on the solar cells themselves.
That's what I do.
And when you look at that data you
realize that, with those expensive
installation costs, what people who make
panels need to do is raise the efficiency.
Because then you can get the power you
need with a lower number of panels.
And you can calculate how valuable it
is to make a panel more efficient.
And if you run those
numbers you find that you
should be willing to pay an extra three
cents per watt for an efficiency point.
So in other words If you could get
a 20% efficient panel instead of 19,
you should be willing to pay $0.53 per
watt for it instead of $0.50 per watt.
And indeed, if you look at the market,
there's a range of products
where the efficiency
goes from 15% efficiency up to about 21.
And indeed,
those are the variations in the price.
In some cases,
people are willing to pay even more.
For example, in the neighborhood where
I live in, in Menlo Park, California.
A lot of people have to pay up
to 40 cent per watt, I'm sorry,
40 cent per kilowatt hour for
their electricity because we have a tiered
system and the more power you use,
the higher rate you have to pay.
And a lot of people are switching
to electric vehicles and
that's raising their electricity needs and
so
they might want to install six or
seven kilowatts of panels on their roof.
But they also don't have very large roofs
and a lot of their roof is not useful
because they have chimneys and vents and
some of the roof might be shaded.
And some of the roofs have complex shapes.
And so they simply can't get
the capacity that they would like
when the panels only have 15 or
16% efficiency.
And so it can make sense for
them to really pay a premium
to get higher efficiency panels.
And so
I think there's a strong drive for that.
And here on the next slide we
can see how the efficiency
has evolved over time for
some of the most important technologies.
Let's start with that black
curve because that's silicon.
And right now about 90,
maybe 92% of the market is crystal and
silicone solar cells.
And the world record efficiency is 25% but
that's for
a small cell and not for
expensive things were done to make it.
The panels would be more
at maybe 15 to 21%.
But the other thing I want you
to see from that curve, is there
is hardly been any progress in raising
that efficiency since the late 90's so
that efficiency is pretty much stagnant.
Above it, that's the green curve,
that's gallium arsenide and
you can go up to 28% with that.
But it's a very expensive
technology right now.
It's about 40 times more
expensive than silicon.
And I don't see a pathway for
a dramatic cost reduction there.
If you look at the pink and blue those
are so called thin film technologies.
Copper, indium, gallium selenide and
cadmium telluride.
And the idea there is to use a smaller
amount of semiconductor to try to
reduce costs, and you can see
the efficiency evolved over time and
now both of them are at 22%.
But, the news of today is that
red curve the perovskite,
it just came out of nowhere.
Around 2012 and
the efficiency has soared up to 22,
catching up with CIGS and
Cadmium telluride.
And never in history has
a semiconductor advanced so quickly for
solar salt applications and
I think they're two reasons for that.
One, there are some very beneficial
properties that I'm getting ready to tell
you about.
And the other is that there's a community
of solar cell researchers who've learned
a lot over the years and these people
really know how to take a new material and
make a good solar cell with it,
so things move faster now.
Maybe there are some of you out there who
don't have an engineering background,
so let me say just a little
bit about semiconductors.
These are materials that have a bunch
of continuous energy levels that
are filled with electrons that make
up what we call the valence band and
then on the energy diagram,
there are a lot of energies where there
are no states that electrons can go into.
And then there's a mostly empty
band called the conduction band and
in between that is something
called the energy band gap, and
I will refer to that number
a lot in this webinar.
When light comes in,
we can excite an electron from
the valence band up to
the conduction band and
it will fall to the bottom of band if
we excite it up high into the band.
And in fall that electron
falls back down in a process,
we call recombination
that energy is stored.
And what we want to do is get the electron
to go to one side of the semiconductor and
get the hole or the positive charge
to go to the other side, and
we want to extract that
power as electricity.
That's basically how a solar cell works.
And the band ap is really important.
Because if we have a large band gap,
then most of the photons in the solar
spectrum don't have enough energy to get
the electron up into the conduction band.
And so, we can't absorb those photons.
On the other hand, if we pick a small band
gap, then the photons excite the carriers
high up into the band and
then they fall to the bottom of the band
in a process we call thermalization and
we lose all that energy.
And so with a low band gap,
we get a low voltage.
With a high band gap, we get a high
voltage, but we get a low current,
because we get one charge
carrier per photon absorbed.
And so on the curve of
efficiency versus band gap,
you see that it starts low,
rises to a peak and then it falls.
And from this we see that
the ideal band gap is about
1.4 electron volts and
with 1 semiconductor,
the highest efficiency you can
get with the Sun is about 31%.
Now, there is a trick.
There's several tricks for
beating that limit, but
I'm going to focus on what I
think is the most important one.
We can make tandems or
other people call them multijunction
solar cells and the idea
is to put a large band gap solar cell
on top of a small band gap solar cell.
When you do that, the high energy photons
are absorbed in the large and gap cell.
And because it has a large band gap,
we can generate a higher voltage.
So we can capture more of
the energy from those photons and
then the low energy photons,
they will go through and
we'll use a second cell with a smaller
band out to harvest those two.
So, we can do better that way.
And theoretically, we can do up to 42%.
But practically for one junction,
silicon is limited to about 25.
And I think practically,
35% might be about the best we
can do with cost-effective means,
but 35% is considerably
more efficient than 25%.
And so, I think it's an attractive goal.
This plot here just shows
the efficiency you can get,
as a function of the band
gaps on the y-axis.
That's the band gap of
the low band gap cell.
The x-axis is the high.
You can see there that 42 is possible and
it tells us that for
this application, the band gaps we want
are about 1.1 electron volts and 1.8.
So some numbers to keep in mind as
I go forward for single junction,
we want 1.4 eV and for
2 junctions, we want 1.1 and 1.8.
Now let me tell you about
the perovskites themselves.
Perovskites are essentially a salt and
you can dissolve them in a polar solvent.
And when you do, you really don't have
perovskite in your vial of solution,
you have ions in there.
But then when you cast it or print it and
form a thin film,
the solvent will evaporate away.
And as it does, this salt will form and
it will be solid and
you will get a crystal structure like you
can see on the right side of the slide.
The word perovskite, what it really
means is just that crystal structure.
It means the atoms
are arranged in that way, but
a specific example of perovskites
that makes a good solar
cell is methylammonium lead iodide,
but there are other options.
And on the next slide, you'll see on the
top as we go from the left to the right,
we're gradually reducing
the amount of iodine and
adding in bromine and
you can see that the color is changing and
that's because the band
gap is increasing from
1.6 electron volts to 2.3 electron volts.
The visible spectrum is
from about 2 eV up to 3 eV.
So when the band gap is 1.6,
the semiconductor can absorb
all of the visible photons and
that makes the film look black.
But as we go to the right, we get to
where the film cannot absorb the red and
then it can't absorb the yellow and
that's why the film starts to be colored.
If you look at the bottom,
we've replaced the methylammonium
with another organic cation called
formamidinium and you see that,
that can drop the band gap
from 1.6 down to 1.48.
And later in the talk, I'll show you
can we can replace lead with tin.
So by changing all of
the elements in the formula ABF3,
we have a variety of knobs for adjusting
the band gap for whatever application.
By the way, if you use chlorine,
you can raise the band gap all the way
up to 3 eV and you can also make red,
green and blue LEDs, but
that would be a top for another day.
On this slide,
you can see the cross section of
a typical perovskite solar cell.
On the left was the original
composition that a few labs.
Like Namgu Park and Tom Niasaka and Henry
Snaith and Michael Gratzfol discovered.
And it evolved from the dye
sensitized solar cell.
It has a film of titanium nanoparticles
filled in with the perovskite and
then sandwiched between
a gold electrode and
a transparent fluorine-doped
tin oxide electrode.
But pretty quickly Henry Snaith
realized that you don't actually need
the titanium nanoparticles.
And you can use the plainer
structure on the right,
where it's just an uninterrupted
film of perovskite.
On the bottom is an energy diagram and one
of the key design rules is shown there.
On the left is Titania and
that's an example of what we call
an electron transport material and
it needs to have its conduction band which
is that top energy level being lower
than the conduction band of the perovskite
that way electrons can go over there.
But holes, which go upward on
an energy diagram, they can't go in.
And that way electrons can
only escape to the left.
In contrast, on the right side,
we have a material,
just generically called
the whole transport material.
It can accept holes, but
it cannot except electrons.
So these materials, sometimes we call them
selective or carrier selective contacts,
and they provide the mechanism to
have electrons go out on one side and
holes on the other.
Perovskites have many
wonderful properties.
We've seen they have a tunable band gap.
They're very highly absorbing, they absorb
as well as any semiconductor out there.
If you illuminate them
with pulses of light,
you can see that the charge
carriers live for a long time.
That means there's very
slow recombination,
which is one of the most desirable
properties for a solar cell.
A lot of semiconductors have
defects at their surfaces and
charge carriers will recombine there,
but that is very slow in the Pervoskite.
For a lot of semiconductors, if you have
a thin film with lots of small crystals,
there will be recombination at
the boundaries between crystals.
But that seems to be very
slow with perovskites.
And it's all of those
properties that make it
possible to get as high as 22% efficiency.
And moreover,
we can print these things even on plastic.
And so we can, we can make a flexible
solar cell at low temperature.
And that's the property that cadmium
telluride and sigs don't have.
So that's the good news.
A balanced webinar has to present
some of the bad news as well.
These materials are very
sensitive to water.
A lot of you probably know
that faults take up water and
these perovskites are no exception.
But that just really means that
the panels need to be packaged well and
it means that you need to cover
the perovskite with an electrode promptly.
In the factory, you wouldn't want to
have perovskite film sitting around,
especially if the factory
were in a humid environment.
So you need to get it packaged promptly.
Another one, it turns out the halogens,
that's the iodine or the bromine,
they move around very easily and they
can react with metal, especially silver.
But I'll show you in a slide or
two how to avoid that problem.
And finally, methylammonium can
leave the film relatively easy.
It'll slowly come out at 80 degrees and
by the time you're at 100,
110 degrees,
it will come out very quickly.
And that could be a problem for
field use, where the temperature,
you might hit 80 degrees C, but it's also
a problem in manufacturing where sometimes
you might have a processing step at,
say, 130 degrees.
My group has figured out how to
mitigate some of these problems.
We wanted to put a transparent
indium tin oxide electrode on top.
That's the material that's used
in your flat panel display and
your laptop and
we wanted to sputter it but it turned out
that process will damage the perovskite so
we needed to put down a buffer layer.
And for that, we used aluminum
doped zinc oxide nanoparticles.
We could deposit those from solution in
a way that did not damage the perovskite.
And then, we could sputter on that.
These are inorganic nanoparticles.
They're a little more robust and
they would protect the perovskite.
And when we did that,
we would put these solar cells on
a hot plate in air at 100 degrees.
And if you look at the picture here,
you'll see the square in the center,
that's where the ITO is.
And in there,
the perovskite maintained its color.
But outside of that, where there was no
indium tin oxide, we found the material
very quickly converted to lead iodide
as the methyl ammonium left the film.
So this demonstrated that the ITO
would hold the methylammonium in and
moreover, we found that iodine doesn't
seem to react with the indium tin oxide.
And so we could run this solar cell
in there with no packaging for
a week, on a hot plate at 100
degrees under one sun illumination.
So this is a very big breakthrough,
switching away from metals to using
the indium tin oxide electrode.
But that's only one of
the things you can do.
Before I give the next, let me just also
point out some other research groups have
found you can also use carbon
paste as an electrode.
Again, showing that the key to stability
seems to be getting away from metal.
And the second paper explains in
detail why gold is problematic.
It actually diffuses into the perovskite.
So the second thing we do to keep
methylammonium from escaping is simply not
use methylammonium and if you use
mixtures of cesium and formamidinium,
you get a compound that we find to
be stable at 150 degrees Celsius.
Cesium is a little bit too small to
properly fit into the perovskite lattice.
Formamidinium is a little bit too large.
But mixtures of the two seem to make a
very robust perovskite crystal structure.
And then the third really
important strategy is
simply to properly
package the solar cells.
And we talked a lot to the team
at DuPont here at Silicon Valley who
makes a lot of these packaging materials.
And then we went to a company called
D2 Solar that packages solar cells and
makes panels for other solar cell startups
that don't have all of that equipment.
And here you put a rubber edge seal that
you can see in black around the edge and
then in the interior,
you have encapsulation made of things
like ethylene vinyl acetate or
an ionomer called cerlen.
And the you pull vacuum to get any
air out and you heat it to about
130 degrees and press on it and
forms a really nice package.
And this is just industry standard
packaging for solar cells.
And then when you do this, you can put
it through a torture test that the solar
industry uses to predict if something
is going to last outside for 25 years.
They test for
1,000 hours at 85 degrees Celsius and
85% humidity,
which is a really aggressive test.
And we did that and
one of our three packages failed.
It leaked and water got in.
But two of them didn't and
we passed this test after 1,000 hours.
Actually, the efficiency increased, and so
this is extremely encouraging
that we passed that test.
So the outlook on stability is that if
you use the more stable Perovskites,
you use impermeable and
unreactive electrodes and
proper packaging, it looks like at least
thermal stability can be obtained.
We've also done a temperature cycling
torture test where we go back and
forth from 80 degrees C into a freezer
at -40 to see if the shrinking and
expansion will cause it to pop apart.
And we passed that on the first time.
And we're working on long-term tests
under light but those take a bit longer.
And at least after 1,000 hours,
things look encouraging.
But it'll be a while before
we'll have longer term tests.
So a year ago,
I was a bit scared over the prospects
of making these devices stable because
they were only lasting for minutes.
But huge progress has been made and
I think the outlook is
positive now on stability.
Now let me turn back to
the Tandem Solar Cell.
So we know this concept works.
The world record is 46% and that's made
with single crystals 3/5 semi conductors.
Basically the Gallium Arsenite family.
I think that world record has
four different band gaps in it.
Unfortunately, those cells are absolutely
tiny because they cost over
$40,000 per meter squared to make.
So I believe the future is a much,
much cheaper tandem.
And on the bottom, I think we could just
use conventional semiconductors like
silicon or copper indium gallium selenide,
which both have the perfect 1.1V band gap.
And then on the top, we need something
that works even when it's not a single
crystal, something that you
would say is defect tolerant.
And the Perovskites have really merged
as an exciting candidate for that.
There are a couple of ways that people
could imagine making these tandems or
actually probably far more than two but
here.
in my view, the two most promising.
You could make a complete Perovskite
cell that has it's own electrodes,
and mechanically stack it on top of,
let's just say a silicon cell
that has it's own electrodes.
An advantage of that is that You can just
use any silicon cell, you could get them
from different companies and they wouldn't
have to modify their product at all.
And you just package
the Perovskite cells on top.
On the other hand, you can make
a monolithic cell where the Perovskite
is directly deposited onto the silicon or
CIGS solar cell.
If you do that,
you have to match the current densities.
If one of them puts out less
current than the other,
it will set the current for the stack, and
that means you have to calculate and
obtain exactly the right band gaps so
that the two cells each get
the right amount of current.
And there's some engineering that has
to be done to make the right interfaces
between the two.
With the mechanically stacked tandem,
you don't have to perfectly current match.
On the next slide I'll show, you can still
wire them up in a series of each other.
You can have a string of silicon and
a series of a string of Perovskite cells.
And you can just simply adjust the areas
in order to get current matching.
And if you do that, your panel will still
only have two wires coming out of it.
A few years ago, my group set out
to demonstrate that all of this was
possible and that the easier one to make
is the mechanically-stacked tandem and
that's what we did, and back then our
Perovskite only had 12.3% efficiency and
we put it on top of 17% efficient silicone
and we also had 17% efficient CIGS.
And when you put those under the
Perovskite, the efficiency of course drops
because a lot of the photons
are absorbed in the top cell.
But you could still get 5.7 and
if you add those up,
you'd get 18, which is better
than either cell by itself.
Since then,
there've been a lot of advances and
I'll just have to skip straight to
the world record and this is from
Christophe Ballif's lab in Switzerland and
with a lot of things optimized.
The efficiency is already at 25%.
And I see a clear path to get
this up to 30% efficiency.
My group was also the first
to demonstrate a two
terminal tandem in
partnership with Tony at MIT.
They made a silicon saw with
a tunnel junction on top.
And then we put a Perovskite
saw on top of it.
And here we got 13.7% and
we identified we were having a big
problem with our whole transport
layer absorbing photons,
which we didn't want to it to do.
But a lot of progress has
been made on that as well.
Now the worldwide community has made
many compositions of Perovskites and
we have a lot to choose from.
We don't have a great 1.0
eV band gap material but
we do have some pretty good
ones with 1.6 electron volts.
And in this next slide you'll see,
with 17% Thesium,
83% Phormidium and
17% Bromine, 83% Iodine,
we've been able to make a 2-terminal
tandem with 23.6% efficiency.
That was a validated world record by NREL,
about ten days ago.
And this is also,
this is the same composition
that passed those damp heat tests
that I talked about earlier.
So when we selected this composition,
it was not only for
efficiency but we were also
selecting it to be very stable.
Finally, I want to tell you about
something that's not published yet
in a peer reviewed journal.
>> In collaboration with Henry Snaith's
group from Oxford, we've figured
out to make a low band gap perovskite and
make all perovskite tandems.
This is on the Archives Journal right now,
as the paper is going through peer review.
And here, we're adjusting the ratio
of lead to tin in the compound.
And if the tin composition is around 50%,
we can get the band gap
down to 1.2 electron volts.
And that's not perfect for
a two-terminal tandem, but
it's getting very close to
being the perfect band gap.
And here, you see the cross-sectional
SCM of a two-terminal tandem.
And right now,
we're at about 17% efficiency and
we understand what some
of the problems are.
Our 1.2 eV material is just far too thin.
We just haven't figured out how to deposit
a thick, high quality film yet, but
I think that will
certainly be figured out.
And we needed a 1.8 eV band gap
to have proper current matching,
but we also need a better composition for
that band gap and
it's a fundamental reason
why that can't be done.
So, I expect the sufficiency
to rise very quickly.
We also made a four-terminal tandem
with the low band gap material.
And right now, we're at about 20%
efficiency and it's a very new material.
We haven't been able to do
full stability testing, but
it was completely stable over
20 hours of testing under 1 sum.
So, I think the outlook for
efficiency and stability is wonderful.
You've seen how the single junction
efficiency rapidly rose to 22,
I'd be very surprised if
it's saturated there.
I'm optimistic that single
junction cells might go to 25 and
that the tandems will go
up over 30% efficiency.
I know someone's going to ask me about
the implications of lead being toxic,
so let me address that before
we turn it over to the Q&A.
There's this paper in
Nature Materials that's written by
toxicologists who have no reason to be
biased towards perovskite solar cells and
they talk about what happens
when people are exposed to lead.
And one thing that is very clear is
that factories would have to be run
in a proper way to protect the workers and
make sure that they're not
exposed to lead, and there are plenty
of industries that use lead,
and other toxic compounds, and
it is possible to protect workers.
And then when the panels expire and
are decommissioned,
it will be very important
to take the panel apart and
properly capture the lead and
then something else to think about.
These panels are only going to have
about one gram of lead in the perovskite
layer and just to put that into
perspective, people may not realize this.
But today,
panels already have 16 grams of lead.
That is in the red solder.
So, it's a very small amount of lead.
And moreover, if you took the panel and
dashed on it for
five minutes of a thread shimmer and
throw it into a lake.
Well then, yes, the lead would escape.
But short of doing things like that,
it would be very hard for
the lead to actually get out
of a properly packaged module
There are five companies that I
know of in the startup stage.
Oxford PV is certainly the largest and
they're developing
a two terminal tandem with
perovskite on silicon.
Full disclosure, I have co-founded
Iris PV with Colin Bailey and
we're taking a different approach.
We are mechanically stacking
perovskites on silicon.
Hunt Energy,
led by Michael Irwin in Dallas.
They're going with single junction
perovskites, so they're going for
an ultra-low cost product and Saule
in Poland seems to be doing flexible.
Perovskite sales and
I don't know a lot about Weihua in China,
but I have seen pictures of
panels that are almost two feet
across that they've already
been able to print.
If you want to learn more,
we have a certificate program on energy
innovations and emerging technology.
I teach a three-hour
module on solar cells.
In that module, I say a whole lot more
about the industry in general and
I go through all of the important
solar cell technologies.
They're not just perovskites.
And more broadly in this certificate,
I think we cover all of
the important topics on energy.
So, you can learn a whole lot there.
These are all the people that are not all,
but some of the people who
helped do the research
that I talked about from Stanford and some
of our partners from outside Stanford and
certainly none of this would
have been possible without them.
With that, I thank you all for
attending and
I will do my best to
answer your questions.
>> Great.
Thank you for
that excellent presentation and for
sharing some of the very latest
research in collaborations.
So now,
I'd like to hand it back over to Mike.
So, he can answer some of the questions
that you've been sending through.
>> They've typed a lot
of the questions for me,
I can see them on the screen and
lots of good ones here.
I'll start with,
are perovskites flexible or rigid?
The films we're using
are about a half micron thick.
And actually, pretty much everything
is flexible when it is that thin.
So, what determines whether or
not the solar cell is flexible is simply
what's substrate it is deposited on.
And because our processing
is at low temperature,
we can build the solar cell on plastic,
which is flexible and
there are indeed demonstrations in
the literature of flexible solar cells.
I will say for applications though,
the plastic will need to
keep the water out for
the lifetime of the product.
And right now,
we don't have any expensive flexible
packages that provide a suitable barrier.
So, it going to be important for
there to be break through on that.
But if the product didn't need to have
a long life time, then it would be
certainly be possible right now to do
flexible perovskite case solar cells.
Another question,
would it be possible to go to 100% tin for
the purpose of getting the lead out?
And people are working hard on that and
I'm not sure what the latest
efficiency is there.
I'm sure people have gotten 8% and
I I think it's in that maybe 8 to 10,
perhaps as high as 12% with all tin.
So it's quite not yet, as good as led.
However, there have been reports that
tin is actually more toxic than lead.
The toxicity of lead is very well known,
but it actually,
as far as toxic things go,
lead is not that bad and there are a lot
of things that are worse that just
somehow haven't picked up the reputation.
So I'm not sure switching to tin for
the purpose of reducing toxicity
is going to be helpful.
People are also switching to bismuth,
which unfortunately doesn't have
the right charge, or
it's not a plus two, it's a plus three.
And then you have to balance that with
a plus one, so if you use silver and
bismuth, for example,
Hema Karunadasa at Stanford does that, but
it's not yet anywhere near as
good as these lead compounds.
So suffice it to say, there are research
groups trying to find lead-free compounds.
Looking at some of the other questions.
People are asking, yeah,
what would the cost of these panels be?
That's a great question.
So we have worked with Mike Woodhouse
at the National Renewable Energy Lab,
who leads a team that does cost modeling.
And they call companies and they find out
what all the materials are going to cost.
And they find out how
much it would cost to
use the tools to do all
of the processing steps.
And people in industry seem
to agree that the results
from that group are pretty accurate.
And so they project that if you just
did single junction perovskite panels,
they'd be just a little bit
cheaper than cadmium telluride,
because you can deposit
the perovskite more easily.
But not dramatically cheaper and that's
because so much of the cost is in things
like the packaging and the junction box,
where the wires come out.
So that's why like when people tell you
they're going to drop the cost by an order
of magnitude using solution processing,
they usually have not accounted for
the packaging.
In the tandems,
the way we like to think of it is,
let's say you have a silicon panel and
you want to upgrade to a tandem.
We project that down the road,
the silicon panel would be
about $80 per meter squared.
We think the upgrade cost is going to
be about $24 per meter squared.
When you convert it to a dollar per watt,
we think that it'll be about the same.
So it'll cost more, but
it'll also be more efficient.
Where you really win is that with these
panels that have over 25% efficiency,
you won't need to install as many of
them to get a given amount of power.
And the big savings will be over on
the installation side of things and
that's why it's compelling to do this.
Okay, let me look at
some of these other ones.
Someone's asking,
what about the performance in
direct versus diffuse light?
So these'll work fine in diffuse light,
unlike gallium arsenide cells,
those are tiny and
they are used with concentrators.
And those are either lenses or reflectors
that focus the light onto the cell,
and they only work with the direct light.
The diffuse light doesn't properly
get through the optical system, but
we won't be using concentration and
so ours will work fine.
There's a fine point
here with the tandems.
Clouds change the spectrum and so
if you have designed your tandem
to work well under the so
called AM 1.5 conditions,
which is a bright day with no clouds,
the tandem might not work
properly with clouds, nor
will it work well at sunrise or
sunset when the spectrum has changed.
It will still work.
And my group and several others
are trying to calculate the loss
over a typical year and it appears
that it could be around 10% to 15%.
It's why I prefer
the mechanically stepped tandem,
because we can use a little circuit
in-between the perovskite and
silicone solar cells to maintain
the current matching condition and
so we wouldn't have to
pay that penalty there.
Someone said,
is there any work in progress to
utilize graphene as a substrate?
Graphene is also a pretty good
transparent conductor and
there are some academic groups
trying to use it as an electrode.
And it would also, I think,
dramatically improve
the stability of the solar cell.
Hardly anything can go through graphene.
I hope there are advances in
depositing large sheets of graphene.
I haven't followed the latest on that, but
I'm not aware of any real practical
way to put down large sheets of it.
I think you could have
lots of small flakes and
that's kind of like those carbon
pastes that I briefly alluded
to that have been used and
they did result in very stable devices.
Someone's asking about printing and
I think this is just being touched on.
And at this time,
I don't think it's clear whether it
should be slot dye coated or
blade coated or gravure coated or
perhaps even ink jet printed
with an array of novels.
I think what is for sure is that it should
not be spin coated at industry scale,
because spin coating doesn't work well for
a very large area and
it also wastes so much of the solution.
So we definitely want a printing
technique where almost
all of the ink does actually
end up in the solar cell.
And only a few labs
are working on the scale
up right now to go to larger area.
There definitely needs to be
a lot more work in that area.
There's a question,
do I think mechanical versus
monolithic will be the better design for
tandems?
So I believe in mechanical and
I have a few reasons for that.
One of them is,
I was saying how if the spectrum
changes during the course of the day or
through the seasons and
the current match is lost,
you could use circuitry to fix it.
Another one is it's just
a practical business concern,
if someone were to make
the high-band gap top cells,
they could partner with any company
that makes either silicon or SIGs.
And those companies would not
have to modify their product.
They wouldn't have to change the texturing
that they used at the top of their cell.
They wouldn't have to change
their electrode pattern.
Whereas if you go monolithic, you've gotta
keep, at the top of your silicon, smooth,
and that's not as easy as it may sound.
Now, some believe in monolithic.
When you do that,
you get rid of one of the transparent
conductors that you need in
the mechanically stacked tandems.
And each one of those conductors
costs you about 10% of the photons.
And so, I'm sure, eventually,
the world record efficiency will
come from a monolithic design.
But what's best to get a world
record in an academic lab and
what's most practical for business,
I think are two different things.
So not surprisingly, people have asked for
the expected time to market.
It's always the toughest question for
a professor to answer.
I've certainly never seen anything
progress as rapidly as this has,
and a lot of times,
the community poses a problem and
it gets solved in just a matter
of three to 12 months.
So things are moving forward very,
very rapidly.
However, I'm anticipating very
serious financing problems.
All of the startups are having
tremendous difficulty raising capital.
A lot of investors lost money,
total of billions of dollars
were lost between 2005 and 2015.
And so
there's a reluctance right now to invest.
And I guess if I look forward here, either
some people are going to step up soon and
invest, or the numbers are just
going to get more and more compelling.
The efficiencies are going to keep rising.
The industry standards.
Stability tests,
I believe, will be passed.
We may see academics and
national labs start the scale up and
demonstrate that there are no issues.
And then hopefully,
investors will be willing to put in
the tens of millions that will
be needed for a pilot line.
And then I think things
could proceed very quickly.
I think one thing some people learned form
the failures of the last decade is that,
you don't want to have eight to
ten innovations at the same time.
You don't want to completely
redesign the panel.
You don't want to get into
a situation where you need
to build custom tools because you're doing
something that's never been done before.
And these designs that I talked about
today, they can all be implemented
with off the shelf tools that you can get
from companies like, Applied Materials.
And you can even like, in Silicon Valley,
the tools are around and
again, you could be using used
tools in a pilot line situation.
And so, in a best case scenario, I think
products could be ready in a few years but
financing problems might extend that.
>> Okay.
Well, thank you for
answering those questions.
And thank you for
those of you who sent them in.
We had a fantastic number.
I think we've all learned
a lot more today.
I want to thank you for
attending the webinar, and
hope that you'll be able to join us again
in the future for other faculty talks.
So, enjoy the rest of your day.